[Music]
you're more than three and a half
kilometers above the earth and there's
no turning back now
but as you jump out of the plane and see
how beautiful the earth looks below you
you start to think this might not be so
bad
then you pull the cord to open your
parachute
and your worst fears come true
[Applause]
there's no parachute coming out and now
you're plummeting towards the ground at
about 200 kilometers per hour
you've only got a minute before you hit
the ground
is there anything you can do to save
yourself
here's how to survive a fall without a
parachute
every time your life depends on a
parachute there's a one in one thousand
chance that it won't work
but a malfunctioning parachute isn't
necessarily a death sentence
according to skydiving experts the
secret to surviving is all about how you
react when the parachute fails
how should you position your body
is there anything you could do to slow
your fall
and why could landing on a roof be
better than landing in a big body of
water
[Music]
the first thing you need to do is slow
your descent
just like most survival situations the
best thing to do is to slow everything
down
slow down your breathing and avoid
hyperventilating
slow down your thoughts so you can focus
and
slow down the speed of your fall so you
don't splatter on the ground
to do that you'll need to spread out
your body into an x shape
spread your arms and legs point your
chest towards the ground and arch your
back and head upward
this will create more air resistance and
slow your acceleration
giving you time to choose where to land
[Music]
step two avoid landing in water
although the giant pool of liquid below
you might look like a more appealing
landing spot than the solid ground
it would probably be just as deadly
like concrete water doesn't compress so
landing in a lake would be just like
landing on a sidewalk sure you could
position yourself to reduce the impact
but
even then you could still be knocked out
cold
and being unconscious underwater does
not help you survive so let's find
somewhere better
step 3 direct yourself to a better
landing spot
to move sideways through the air
away from the water and towards a safer
target
you'll need to use a skydiving technique
called tracking
bring your arms and legs in against your
body to steer it as you fall
your three best options for landing
spots would be a swamp
snow
or trees
because
they would all extend your deceleration
time and help you slow down
for instance if you were to land on
solid ground your body would decelerate
from its falling speed of 200 kilometers
per hour to zero kilometers per hour in
half a second
hitting you with enough g-force to kill
you instantly
but if you were to land somewhere that
provides more cushioning
you could extend that deceleration by a
couple of seconds which would
significantly reduce the g-force
and give you a better chance of
surviving
if you can't see a swamp snow or trees
anywhere nearby then
your next best option would be to look
for something big to break your fall
like a rooftop or a bus
these structures are not very strong so
when you hit them they'll break and
absorb some of the energy of your fall
step 4
land on your feet
so now it's the moment of truth you've
chosen your target landing spot and now
you're going to hit it
the best way to do this would be to
point your toes toward the ground and
land on the balls of your feet
i know what you're thinking that sounds
painful and you're right it will be
but the idea is that your body will have
more time to slow down if you land feet
first
the long bones in your legs will absorb
a large amount of the impact energy
before they fracture
essentially you'll be sacrificing your
legs to protect the rest of your body
step 5 cover your head
just before landing put your head down
with the fingers of each hand locked
together behind it and point your elbows
in front of your face to protect your
head and neck from impact
the main reason why people die from
falling off tall buildings and bridges
is severe head trauma
even if you do everything else right
if you end up bouncing on your head when
you land you won't survive
so quickly get into position
that should be all you need
uh
are you still there
all right now here comes the hard part
you need to figure out where you are and
get help as soon as possible
but don't worry we've got just the video
to help you get out of this alive
[Music]